flashing lights but no sign of alarm the
PM arriving at number 10 to appoint his
new cabinet busy day prime minister
certainly a big one this his fast
reshuffle since the election no major
surprises expected this was to be a
moderate moving of the pieces he assumed
it to all smiles walking into number 10
but into a trap a change of mood as the
Chancellor was told he could keep his
job but only if he agreed to sack all of
his advisers and let number 10 jointly
run number 11 a power grab too far I was
unable to accept those conditions I
don't believe any self-respecting
Minister would accept such conditions
and so therefore I thought the best
thing to do was to go his replacement
Rashi's sunic arrived at the Treasury
with a bigger job than he'd expected
delighted to be appointed lots to get on
with thanks very much a job too big for
him says his opposite number the
Treasury now weaker and the Chancellor
controlled by the PM's chief adviser you
need a strong Treasury why do you need a
trauma Treasury someone has got to say
is this policy property Costard you need
a chancellor who can do that you can't
have a laptop there and that's what mr.
no-kiss you think he's a puppet a lap
dog a stooge I think he is but he's not
even a stooge and a laptop to the Prime
Minister mr. Dominic Cummings an advisor
and that is remarkable
a change of chancellor but other key
roles remain the same Dominic rabe is
still the foreign secretary Priti Patel
remains Home Secretary and Michael gave
is still at the Cabinet Office but with
a beefed up role but others no longer of
use let go Northern Ireland secretary
Julian Smith out and real ed some one of
several brexit he is sacked they helped
push the Prime Minister into power now
he's pushing them out it wasn't meant to
be a spectacle but a minor reshuffle has
now turned into a major crisis no Prime
Minister wants to lose
Chancellor just a month before the
budget but Sajid Javid is gone cabinet
loyalists tell me it's better for the
Prime Minister to take control of the
Treasury now at the height of his
authority but there are others who
worried that the untrammeled power now
concentrated in number 10 could lead to
bad decision-making but for now at least
mr. Johnson's only emboldened he has a
huge majority and now a cabinet under
his total control the deck reshuffled
but only room for one king bethe Rigby
Sky News Westminster